the threat of antibiotic resistant
infections is dramatically larger than
previously thought
the CDC says drug-resistant infections
kill more than 35,000 people a year and
that's the equivalent of about one
person every 15 minutes new antibiotics
are needed but the experts say not
enough are being developed that's a
problem
our investigative correspondent Anna
Werner discovered the unsettling reason
why so Anna what'd you find out this
very scary stone as in so many things
experts say in this case it comes down
to money new antibiotics are expensive
to develop and because their use is
limited there's not a lot of profit
potential for pharmaceutical companies
but they're badly needed say doctors who
are seeing more and more patients with
infections they can't cure he's just a
teenager Roxana Sudduth says her son tre
a healthy high school freshman loved
sports he would just want to be with his
friends and get better at football and
get better at basketball but she says
after playing basketball with his
friends near their Jacksonville Florida
home in May trade developed a sore on
his foot and it just looked like a small
Buster he also had pain in his legs
doctors gave him antibiotics but the
next day he said mom I can't this help
there hurts too much I can't walk she
took him to the hospital where they told
her 15 year-old Trey had a
life-threatening infection MRSA a
bacterium resistant to antibiotics he
had blood clots all over his legs and in
his lungs over 19 days his condition
deteriorated until finally doctors told
his mother it was time to take Trey off
life support there was nothing that they
could do because the antibiotics weren't
taking the MRSA way MRSA was still there
and and they said the antibiotics
weren't working they said then nobody
nothing was you know there was nothing
was working
Trey's isn't the only case we have seen
infections that are resistant to all the
antibiotics that we have available
dr. Helen Boucher is chief of infectious
diseases at Tufts Medical Center in
Boston she's
newer drugs are critical how soon do you
need new antibiotics well we need them
yesterday and and yes yesterday not not
now but yesterday
well truly we need more options for our
patients yesterday are now a big part of
the problem
many major pharmaceutical companies have
gotten out of antibiotic development now
it's mostly small companies like
Pennsylvania's para Tech Evan Lowe is
CEO there's only about 13 or 14 of us
today that are actually working on
antibiotics as small biotech companies
para tech says its new antibiotic new
Zyra treats pneumonia and skin
infections with fewer toxic side effects
but it's been a tough sell at many
hospitals where budgets are tight and
federal Medicare reimbursements for
antibiotics are low payers and hospitals
have said you know we have our generics
we need to control our costs we'll just
go ahead with the older antibiotics that
we have here today they're telling us
that they don't want our innovation in
response to questions the American
Hospital Association told us its members
are dedicated to the judicious and
appropriate use of antibiotics but dr.
Boucher says we've been forced to go
back and take some old drugs off the
shelf that we would never use because of
the toxicities that associated with them
so you in some cases are using older
drugs because you don't have a newer
better option absolutely you're using
older more dangerous drugs
yes paratext president Adam Woodrow says
fixing the system will take action from
Congress
we'll have to see some form of
legislation to enable drug companies to
survive in this environment so in other
words you're looking at a situation
where without help the industry could go
under without help the industry could
collapse something critical to families
I just wish I could see him one more
time and I didn't know how much I loved
it I just want to see him mm-hmm
there is a bipartisan proposal in
Congress called the disarm Act that
would change the way Medicare reimburses
for antibiotics to allow for higher
payments to hospitals we spoke with one
of the
sponsors a Senator Casey who says the
goal is to stabilize the market so more
medications are available or would be
available but there's also a complicated
problem you really feel for Trey's mom
very much and you know there's 35,000
other Americans who die every year in
similar circumstances so why aren't
companies working to create more
medications for them well it's
complicated because the companies you
know a lot of drugs you can make money
on them time after time after time
diabetes cancer heart disease right
people take these prescriptions month
after month year after year
antibiotics are great because you come
in you can play cure somebody it's a
single use only and then there's this
payment system where under Medicare you
bundle expenses for a particular
diagnosis in a hospital that's how they
often get paid and they say well if you
raise the cost of the antibiotic then it
doesn't fit under the bundle oh yeah so
you know basically that's why these drug
companies these startups are saying and
these small companies are saying we need
help yeah there's only 13 to 14 of them
now it really is just that was
especially tough because it started out
its seemingly such a simple thing yeah
yeah it could be fixed right versus
tough I think it's what you call a
market failure that's what people are
saying the market is broken exactly Anna
thank you very much